Hey, y'all.
I'm JD Long, and I
thought I'd pick up
our lecture from where we left
it off last year at my session.
Actually, it was a
little bit uncomfortable,
because I thought I was going
to come in here and totally
troll the crap out of you guys.
And because I'm going to talk
about Excel and spreadsheets,
I got nothing left,
so I just made up
another presentation in the
last 5 seconds of the keynote.
So let's just kind
of go together
and see where this goes.
Now, I'm Vice President
of Risk Analytics
at a global reinsurance company.
And don't worry, nobody else
knows what that means either.
And it was very confusing
for my daughter,
when she was growing up.
So I'd go to parent-teacher
conference and things.
You've got to explain like,
oh, well, what do you do?
And so I just had
shirts printed up,
because it made everything
easier to explain.
So I'm very empathetic to
the role of spreadsheets.
My whole life has been around
spreadsheets and programming.
I've got to give a
quick disclaimer.
I'm going to mention that
I work at RenaissanceRe,
and I usually never mention it,
because the stock trades down
every time I'm associated
with the company.
I'm not giving financial
advice, and I'm not giving
forward-looking statements.
My junk is on GitHub, though.
Feel free to get
this presentation.
Anything that went
into it will be there.
So this was my great
trolling comment
I was going to lead
with, that I thought
was going to be provocative
but kind of seems
lame in comparison to
what we just sat through.
So to migrate Excel
analysts to coding,
help them be better
at Excel first.
This is kind of what I'm
going to progress with today.
And if you fail to migrate
them to R or anything else,
at least you'll have better
Excel, and that's not nothing.
So I'm coming from
an environment
of a workplace that's
largely based around Excel.
Now, I am suspicious the
business analyst work
environment is not that
different than analysts
in non-profit, or people
who work in maybe finance,
or other places, other
types of organizations.
So I'm going to speak my
first-person experience, which
is around business, but I think
a lot of this is applicable.
Some of you all may know me.
I run my mouth on
Twitter way too much.
Been involved in the art
community there for years.
Paul Teetor, a friend
of mine-- he and I
are working on second edition
of this book for O'Reilly.
We're in final
editing, coming soon
to fine booksellers near you.
And no presentation
at this conference
would be complete without
an Allison Horst diagram.
Now, unlike everyone else
who is lifting things
that Allison put on Twitter,
this was a custom piece.
Allison and I discussed
what I was presenting,
and she came up with this,
and I think it's fantastic.
So corporations tend
to be sad silos.
We've got our business user,
Clippy, and Excel, and Word,
and they all go to the
same parties together.
And GitHub is over here
with the codery type people.
Jupyter's a little
concerned, because he's
been reading all
the crap on Twitter
about how notebooks
might not be a good idea,
and he's a little nervous.
And RMAN has beautiful
plots but is all
alone over in the corner.
And I am here to tell you, it
doesn't have to be this way.
So we can have a totally
different relationship
with these tools, but it's
not going to be the default.
And I am convinced the reason
we end up with everybody
in their own little
silos is, largely, we're
tribal animals, right?
We look and we say,
oh, I am a coder.
Therefore, I value using
these tools this certain way.
And the way you're using the
tool looks illegitimate to me,
because you don't have unit
test, and you don't have this,
and you don't always use
version control the way
I would use version
control, and therefore, I'm
more legitimate than you.
And yes, totally what we just
listened to earlier today.
I think we need to broaden
our tent a little bit.
And this is very much the theme
we just heard in the keynote,
that we're using
some similar tools--
we, between programmers,
analysts, business analysts,
people who use Excel only--
we're using some
different tools,
but there's some overlap.
And I'm not going to be
using Python or R or any
of the coding tools
in quite the same way
that the professional
developers who I work with use.
But I'm still using them,
and it's still production.
And what's important for
us to think about is,
nobody wants to learn coding.
All we want to do is,
we want to kick ass.
And if you go into helping
other people learn a new tool
and your mindset is, I'm going
to use a pedagogical method
to profoundly change the way
they think-- nobody cares.
Like, nobody cares.
They want to be a superhero, and
it's important to think about,
how do analysts
think of themselves?
They're solving problems.
They're doing heavy lifting.
And they're doing it
all while it's on fire.
And they are not going to take
the time to necessarily learn
a completely new
philosophy about how
to think about the
world, because they're
too busy fighting fires
and wanting to kick ass.
So if you approach
helping people get better
at what they're doing,
we need to think
about how we help them,
because we often don't exactly
help them get there
in a way that's
meaningful to where they are.
Now, who in here has
heard of Kathy Sierra?
Anybody?
Because I'm totally
ripping off-- like,
the rest of my presentation
is Kathy Sierra rebranded.
She was a developer advocate
before developer advocacy
was even a thing.
She wrote a number
of books on Java--
comes from a Java background--
but all the way down
to the phrase "kicking ass"
comes from Kathy Sierra here,
and I'm just recirculating
it for our use case.
But she has this wonderful
graph about learning,
and there's this suck threshold,
and what we're trying to get to
is the passion threshold.
So what gets people feeling
passionate about any tool is,
they feel like they're
kicking ass with it.
And the suck threshold
is when it is horrible,
nothing makes sense,
and we can't figure out
what to do next.
And if we start
trying to teach--
especially to these firefighters
dead lifting flaming weights
and is worrying about the
whole company coming down--
and if we spend
trying to teach them,
here's 5 different types of
objects you may encounter,
you're just moving
along the time axis,
and you aren't moving
them up the ability axis.
So my key takeaway
here is, as you're
trying to talk to people
in your organization
about upping their
skill, whatever
the skill is, get them doing
things they perceive as useful.
Way more important than
learning a body and knowledge.
Now, back to my whole OK,
help people migrate Excel
by helping them be
better at Excel.
Let me give us some
specific examples,
because that's a bit oblique.
This is Excel in Mac with the
dark theme, because I'm cool.
Very hip.
Tell my 11-year-old.
OK, so we've got
this workbook called
Iris workbook, because we've
got to use Iris, right?
Even though it's Excel.
I'm blending cultures here.
We've got this Iris
workbook, and I've
introduced a sheet
called Iris sheet,
and it has a table
in it-- a named
table-- called Irish table.
Now, the concept
here that I think
is very important for users
of Excel to begin to use
is this idea of a named table.
Who in here is
familiar with this idea
of naming a table in Excel?
OK, cool.
So a big chunk of people.
I have noticed this is
used very inconsistently,
and sometimes analysts who
are experienced with Excel
don't even know this exist.
And it's important to help them
understand the value of this,
because you can do really
neat things, like reference
columns in a function.
That feels a little
bit like using
a programming language, right?
So this is my other
provocative idea
that's no longer
provocative that's,
we're learning programming
in a reactive functional
environment, and that's good.
This isn't a problem.
This is a good thing.
And we're helping an analyst,
or a traditional Excel user,
begin to think about a data
frame, and named columns in it,
and doing operations on those.
And this is a vectorized
operation, and it's super.
They can then use these
things other places,
like use that table name
when they make a pivot table.
This is a natural segue
into things we do and are.
One of the other things
that's very tempting
to do when you know the tools
that we all know is to say,
oh, I'm going to
take your workflow,
and I'm going to help
you fix it, right?
And I'm going to help you--
we're going to just
do it all over in R.
The philosophy that I have
adopted after failing miserably
at that and basically
being told to go sod off
is, help people take the hard
parts, the high friction parts,
and build some
automation around that.
Don't feel like
we have to change
someone's life completely.
Make an incremental change.
We've started, in my team,
calling this the 10% better
approach rather than trying
to completely fix a workflow.
Every time we do it, we
try to make it 10% better.
We have made more progress
through the 10% improvement
approach than we have through
any number of projects that
were grandiose and,
ultimately, failed,
because the scope was too big.
But I can make anything
I do 10% better.
But that R environment, though.
So one of the challenges
for new R users
is setting up the environment.
So where I work, we've
taken it out of the system.
We use JupyterLab lab anyway,
so we have a JupyterLab log in.
Log someone in.
Gives them the R kernel, right?
That's pretty familiar.
And it authenticates the user,
mounts their drive space,
loads their scripts.
But we've got an extra
menu option in ours,
because we just launch
our studio from here--
you're authenticated--
and a user
can play with R without having
to put a request into IT,
without having to work out
those database connections.
It's just there.
And the ability for low
friction play is important.
Now, I agree-- it's not
enough to just have it
there and expect
users to gravitate
and start doing things with it.
But if they don't have
to ask permission-- like,
they don't have to get a
service desk ticket in order
to get a piece of
software installed--
the probability of them
playing, experimenting, doing
something goes way up, and
especially if you've already
got database connections
defined, or file paths,
or whatever makes sense
in your organization.
Now, Excel can be a bit of the
vise grip locking plier tool,
right?
It's a fantastic tool.
Does all kinds of things--
make dashboards with it.
It's fantastic.
We can put a user
interface on top of it.
It's fantastic.
And we use Excel, right,
in a lot of the same ways.
But this is the assembly line.
Obviously, right?
So this is a professional
production environment.
I can't tell from
the picture, but I
guarantee there's 25 pairs
of vise grip locking pliers
in this assembly floor, right?
The principle is, the tools--
it isn't, oh, professional
production tool versus not
a professional production tool.
Vise grip pliers are used
in production, right?
They just aren't holding the
doors on with them, right?
They're being used for
very specific purposes.
Let's give an
example of a workflow
that I have found helpful
in illustrating pulling data
in and out of Excel, right?
Because remember, the objective
is not get someone out
of Excel.
It's, how do we make
their workflow easier?
Well, a common piece is,
do an ETL process in R,
plop the data in an
Excel spreadsheet
where you're refreshing
existing data, right?
And a lot of the
tools kind of assume
you're exporting to
Excel from nothing,
but I have a world
where analysts
have built lots of good
something inside their Excel.
So hey, let's open Excel SX,
and let's drop in our Iris data.
We can do that with the
write table function.
And the thing I would
like to point out
is the two lower parameters--
table style and table name.
This is where we get
named tables in Excel,
by using this feature.
So if they have built, in their
spreadsheet, formulas already
referencing tables
and columns, as I
have been trying to
encourage them to do,
we can replace their data now.
Best practice-- I don't
illustrate it here--
delete the first table out,
and then drop the new in.
Because otherwise, if
you drop fewer rows
in than were
underneath it, you've
got bad data peeking
out the bottom.
Not good.
So delete the first
out-- and that's
not shown in this workflow--
but then write it in.
Give it a name table, and
it is in their environment
where they're used
to working with it.
And we have just made
their process hopefully,
at least, 10% less
painful, right?
This is the entry joke, right?
The first hit's free.
I think, right now, Mike
Smith is giving a presentation
showing this exact same XKCD So
this is getting some legs here.
We had a logical fallacy,
in my team, for a long time.
At least, I perceive it
as a logical fallacy.
We looked at this,
and this is the whole,
if it takes a long time
to automate a task,
but it doesn't save you a
lot of time, don't do it.
Kind of seems obvious.
Well, this illustration-- like
so many things-- is a model.
Like, that's a model of reality.
That isn't actually
reality, and it's wrong,
because all models are
wrong by definition.
They're actually fairly
useful to the extent
the assumptions hold.
Let me tell you a few of
the assumptions that are
wrong with this image, right?
So one of the assumptions is,
all time is of equal value.
So we can't take 5
hours to fix this,
because it doesn't
save us that much time.
It doesn't save us 5 hours over
the course of some time period.
The fallacy there, in my
world, is unequal time value.
So right around the
end of the quarter,
we have a flurry of
reporting activity.
And that time is
incredibly precious.
August, however--
nobody's there.
Who cares what we
do in August, right?
So we can take time
in August, and if we
can save a few
minutes or a few hours
during our very, very busy
period, that's a great return.
And it's because our time
isn't of equal value.
The other thing is, the
current frequency of reporting
is what we would want
to do in the future.
And we have found this
not to be the case at all.
As we have automated
things, we discover
we run them more often, and we
want to run them more often.
We want to get the
analysis that we thought
we only needed once a quarter.
Oh, if we can get
that daily, well, that
might change how we do things.
So it ends up not
being stationary.
All time spent doing
analytics is of equal utility.
Some tasks are so awful and
tedious that your analysts
will quit and go work to
Facebook instead of doing them,
right?
Don't make your
analysts run away.
Help them automate
those manual processes,
not because they
take a long time,
but because they suck their joy.
And the other assumption
that's fallacious
is that automated
and manual workflows
produce the same product.
This is not the case.
The product produced out
of an automated process
should be more accurate
if you're doing it right.
And if it's not, it's at
least inaccurate in scale,
which is fantastic.
The idea of our
10% better approach
came from Dan Harris's book
10% Happier, about meditation.
And we used to
call it, actually,
our incremental
improvement process,
but then we had a different
project called Incremental,
and we can't have
a naming clash,
and naming things is hard.
So anyway, we ended up calling
this process 10% happier.
And we have found that
it is truly-- sorry,
10% improvement-- we found that
it has made us 10% happier.
And we're more time, in this
dynamic environment, where
our tools are getting along,
and the people aren't in silos.
And this is, obviously,
not where we live everyday,
but it's the state that we're
aspiring to be and more.
So with that, I'll wrap up.
I want to point
out, the art here
is by the wonderful
Allison Horst.
Shout at her on Twitter.
She's fantastic, and
wonderful, and did these.
We dialogued only
online, and she
came up with this
wonderful artwork,
so I've got to thank her.
Now, I've got a minute
for some questions.
Let's see.
We've got mics.
[INAUDIBLE]
Oh, go for it.
Where could I get that shirt?
So I had this custom
made, and I realized,
as I was coming
up here, I'm like,
oh, I guess I should
have done, like,
an Etsy store or something,
because I kind of think
that this may resonate.
This may be other people's
love language as well as mine.
We've got other questions?
Right back here.
Do you have other resources
that you utilize for how
to kind of [INAUDIBLE]?
Yeah, that's a good idea.
The question was, do I have
other tips or resources?
I'm afraid that I
don't, and the ones I do
have are super focused on
the workflows that we do.
But I think this is a
neat idea, and if someone
would put together an
online resource of this--
and I'll give some
thought to it--
I think that would be fantastic.
Because I'm sure there
are design patterns
that get repeated over and over,
like my example of popping data
out and popping it in.
I'm suspicious that's a
common design pattern.
But sorry, I don't
have anything.
All right.